devant son agora emmanuel macron a
évoqué plusieurs engagements la
proportionnelle au parlement ou encore
la limitation dans le temps du cumul des
mandats
marc c'est vraiment faire du soi-disant
neuf avec du vieux avec des paroles
qu'on a déjà entendu avec des
propositions qu'on a déjà entendu primo
pour définir emmanuel macron vous
choisirez quelques sympathiques et avec
le sourire comme seul projet politique
prédit aujourd'hui un cynisme à visage
souriant doublé d'un populisme monde à
ce que manuel valls appelle un populiste
light peut-on imaginer sérieusement
commander aux destinées du pays ou même
simplement se présenter aux suffrages
des français alors que sa probité
personnelle a été mise en cause
monsieur macron donne des leçons très
bien c'est son droit
vous savez ce qui arrive aux donneurs de
leçons en général ça leur revient dans
la figure
voilà si c'est ça la politique moderne
très bien car il a trahi la confiance il
a piétiné le gouvernement et les
caterpillar de la gauche qui l'a servi
et qui a fait de lui un ministre de la
république parti j'avais quitté le
gouvernement pour aller rallier
quelqu'un qui était plus haut dans les
sondages
je pourrais vous vous êtes très haut
dans les sondages et vous menacer
françois hollande dans les sondages je
pourrais être un traître c'est ce qu'on
avait reproché à nicolas sarkozy quand
il avait quitté le projet chirac pour
aller rejoindre monsieur balladur est ce
que je fais ça aujourd'hui
cette première l'instant moi j'ai
toujours été prête à taux plein temps je
suis prête à tout avec lui c'est une
créature d'abord françois hollande et ce
système à l'appliquer quand on est une
créature de françois hollande de dire
qu'on va
tout changer je pense qu'il perpétuera
le système bien plus qu'il ne
transformera pas en quoi il est bon
emmanuel macron politiquement il est bon
partout pas que politiquement elle est
très restrictif
qu'est ce que le casque qu'est ce qui
vous plaît politiquement chez lui ses
qualités c'est pas encore trouvé un
domaine où il est pas bon paris jean
marie le pen attaque aujourd'hui en
justice le parti qu'il a créé et dont il
a été exclu les plus d'un an
il exige sa réintégration au fn ainsi
que des dommages et intérêts alors que
même les hommes politiques ont tracker
et une situation comme celle-là peut
créer des chagrins évident mais il ne
passe derrière les nécessité absolue de
la vie politique quand on est dans la
politique on est au service du pays
pour vous la politique passe avant la
famille bien sûr vous dit à jean jacques
bourdin si je perds la présidentielle
j'arrête la politique exactement que ce
que j'ai fait c'est à dire vous avez des
parités pendant deux ans et demi si
parfait j'ai cru entendre l'avocat du
mrap d'ailleurs fait non c'était celui
du front national
et oui c'est ce que voulait nous sommes
tous décidés à salekhard nous partirons
et vous aussi dans une caisse en bois ce
sera comme ça on se demande pourquoi
vous m'invitez mesures en tous cas la
dose qu'elle a si vous voulez c'est
mieux ou ferme l'émission je vous dis
merci au revoir